-You obviously can't watch
your stage work,
but you could watch
your film work.
But you do not like to do that.
-Right, well, 'cause
I'm used to doing plays.
I came from
a theater background.
So it never really equated to me
that why would I want
to watch that.
So long as I know what it feels
like, that's good enough for me.
-But then it was problematic
because you were an actual
"Star Wars" fan, so you then --
Could you not watch the new
"Star Wars" movies?
-I did. I did. I did.
Well, because also, I mean --
Defend myself 'cause all my
friends afterwards, like,
"You didn't watch our movie,
but you watched 'Star Wars.'"
But you're standing in front of
the screen, and they're like,
"Trust us.
Your lightsaber is working."
"There's space behind you.
It looks really cool."
So when you're, like, just
standing in a rainy backlot,
it doesn't seem very impressive.
-Yeah.
-You don't feel like
you're commanding anybody
other than sticks
and ping-pong balls.
-[ Laughs ]
I did once go to a set
that was green screen,
and I was really excited.
And I had this real moment
where I was like,
"Oh, I'm not
supposed to be here."
Just watching a really good
actor act with, like,
you know, a tennis ball
on a stick, you're like --
-"I have this in my basement."
-Yeah.
"I could just watch 'Star Wars'
in my basement now."
"BlacKkKlansman."
Congratulations
on your nomination.
-Oh, thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know that that --
So, when that premieres
at Cannes,
do you skip that out, too?
Like, I mean, obviously,
you're invited to the premiere.
-Yes, yeah.
Well, Cannes is very like --
They're very --
I don't want to say serious,
because you're kind of like,
"Yeah, films are
this important."
You, like, walk up this, like,
kind of sacrificial steps
like you're going to kill a goat
together or something.
And then everyone goes in,
and we watch a movie.
But you have to be back
'cause the lights come up,
and then they put the camera
where you were sitting.
And if you're not there,
it looks bad.
So I just go into a room
and then wait, you know,
with a guy in silence.
And then, you know,
"Okay, now I got to go back
and sneak in and pretend like
I was there the whole time."
-I mean, I get not wanting
to watch yourself.
But being willing to do
the other -- I mean, like,
going out to dinner
is one thing,
but, like, going in a room
with a stranger, I feel like...
You should just try to push
through and watch the movie.
-I know. Yeah, I guess that does
sound really bleak.
It always seems like a better
alternative than watching
all the mistakes
that you're making
that's now immortalized
on film forever.
-Yeah. Real quick,
because you mentioned
Arts in the Armed Forces.
We've talked before about
your military background.
How many years now running
is this?
-Ten years. We've been
doing it for ten years.
-That's amazing.
-Yeah, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I assume you keep doing it
because you're getting
such good feedback.
Is it growing, as well?
Are you getting out
to more people?
-Yeah, when we started, we were
still students at Juilliard,
and we were doing it,
like, in our apartment.
Handtyping, you know,
on a typewriter
'cause we thought
that was very cool.
Thank-you notes to people.
We had enough for
one performance a year.
That's all we could do
while we were still students.
And now we have
incredible donors,
and we're doing 15 performances
already this year.
We just came back
from Fort Leavenworth.
And we have, like, branched out
and have done
this playwrighting grant --
$10,000 to anyone in
the military to write a play
about anything,
about ping-pong balls.
-Right.
-I know I'm referencing you.
-I'm that guy.
-So we're kind of exploring
what the whole arts --
Not just theater,
but we'll still do, you know,
have, like, this
traveling troupe of actors
that go around the world
performing for military
audiences, either veterans,
servicemen and women and their
families, at any base or --
We do an annual performance
on Broadway every year.
-That's great.
Thanks for doing that.
And thanks for being here, man.
It's always such a pleasure.
Really appreciate it.